2018's Halloween pushes beyond the limits
of a normal slasher flick, particularly its
rather abrupt ending.
If you're itching to unravel the different
moving parts left in the wake of Michael Myers'
latest rampage, here's Halloween's ending
and aftermath explained.
Oh, and it should go without saying, but spoilers
for the entire film are ahead.
We learn by the end of Halloween that Michael
Myers isn't the only source of darkness in
the film.
This time, the doctor who's fascinated by
him takes things to a truly dangerous level.
He reveals his true colors when he murders
Sheriff Frank Hawkins rather than let Michael
die, all in an effort to truly understand
the serial killer.
Sartain's heel-turn seems to indicate that
the bus crash that kicked the movie's murder
spree off was almost certainly his doing.
While we never actually see how that happened,
Sartain's obsession with Michael and the fact
that Myers was locked in the back of the bus,
while Sartain sat up front near the driver
sure makes it seem like the not-so-good doctor
was the reason the bus crashed and Michael
went free.
Karen Strode spends much of Halloween outwardly
fearful of and hostile toward her mother,
who she blames for her own dysfunctional life.
Then, in an instant, with her back against
the wall, Karen Strode remembers what her
mother taught her, luring Michael Myers into
the basement stairway just long enough to
get off a wounding shot and begin the process
of trapping the monster once and for all.
It's a cathartic moment not just because it
proves that Laurie was right to be prepared
all along, but also because it allows Karen
to turn all that fear and distraction she's
been grappling with her whole life into a
moment of genuine power.
Laurie carries most of the burden of the confrontation
with Michael, but all three Strode women change
in the process, and Karen's change might end
up being the most powerful if she can learn
the right lessons from it.
In the final moments of the movie, we see
that Laurie's granddaughter Allyson has not
yet let go of Michael's knife, which, just
moments earlier, she used as a key weapon
in fighting him.
The way the knife hangs limp and bloody in
her hand seems like a very clear visual reference
to the way in which young Michael held his
first knife after his own first murder back
in 1963, when he was just a boy.
Is Allyson simply shell-shocked from the violence,
or is something deeper and darker at work
here?
Perhaps we'll find out one day.
By the end of this film, Laurie Strode herself
has become a legend in contrast to that of
Michael's own.
She's built on the reputation she's established
as the paranoid old woman who lives out in
the woods, and has become something more.
She's the Woman Who Killed The Boogeyman.
We don't get to see any of the aftermath of
that play out in this film, but it's a powerful
narrative, and any number of journalists and
other public figures are bound to take an
interest in telling her story, and perhaps
setting Laurie on the road to true recovery.
Now it's time to discuss what will undoubtedly
be the most-debated, most important element
of Halloween's ending: Whether or not Michael
Myers is actually dead.
This film ignores all the previous sequels,
so we go into it with no real hint that Michael
is anything but a sadistic killer.
He's evil, but physically he's just a guy,
right?
Well, that's a question a potential sequel
might need to explore, because while it's
clear that Laurie, Karen, and Allyson are
able to trap Michael in the basement and then
light the whole house on fire, it isn't clear
if that actually kills Michael.
We see a few moments where he's surrounded
by flames, but the last thing we see happen
at Laurie's place is the fire beginning to
engulf the exterior of the house.
We do get one more shot of the basement as
the house burns…and he's not there.
We don't ever see a body, which leaves plenty
of wiggle room for Michael to escape, whether
through supernatural means or just wriggling
through a gap in the floorboards because,
remember, Laurie shot through them at one
point.
And of course, viewers who stayed through
the credits got to hear some creepy, ominous
breathing before leaving the theater.
Sure seems like a heavy hint that Michael
indeed found a way to survive...